a group of Jade miners stand over a vast
open pit the valley below filled by
torrential rain
miners searching for the precious stone
along the banks
warn them it's going to fall say those
above
steep walls seem to be shifting Cascade
of rocks
then the whole Hillside collapses
as it hits the water a tsunami wave
sweeping away everything in its path
from the other side of the valley
workers try to point out survivors tiny
specks swirling around in the muddy
whirlpools as more of the Hill slides
into the water
we were at the spot where the large
water wave Struck it was a huge wave
we were able to flee the area by running
that's the only reason we survived
Rescuers have been struggling for days
to recover bodies from the site very few
survived the initial landslide
heavy rains hampering the rescue effort
in this remote part of Northern Myanmar
boats on the reservoir only able to drag
the murky Waters with hooks
more than 250 people died in similar
accidents in myanmar's Jade mines last
year
a precious stone that exacts a very high
price Tony Chang Al Jazeera